[Musique]
salido ça laisse au final c'est le récit
ma copine c'est une amie qui n'a pas
juste une demi-heure quoi je ne pourrais
pas avoir une relation durable risque
pour toi une femme et intéressant
l'intérêt non mais bon je peux très bien
changer une marge dentaire dit qu'on
veut quand il veut parier paru toit et
de réglisse et comme une lettre à la
poste qui doit te débrouiller pour les
accords qui cherchent une relation
durable et monogame bien sûr bien
s'accrochera non pas du tout quelque
chose me dit qu'il a une demande
particulière en fer et coach porter le
combat ambitieux addict aux mecs qui
sont signés lydia à tusson bien profonde
à sa moitié ma voiture un abc la nisa
mousse polyuréthanne bons tuyaux
d'échappement
tu n'aurais pas nouveau styliste lensois
résistance buzzer
en aac est donc qu ils à vivre comme un
homme étape ci arrivera jamais si tu
arrives à bouger ton petit doigt de pied
de cette main est tendue
ça veut dire qui tu peux avoir des plans
sexe sans amour virtuel et le plus grand
show la fin de toute la ville ces femmes
ou filles de mon patient et je tombe
amoureuse de nice et instructif
d'accord je ne veux pas brûler il s'est
collé contre moi et à ce moment j'ai
senti que ça lui plaisait comment est-ce
que tu la sens
le prince avec une saucisse oui et non
sans cynisme agit là
[Musique]
j'ai une nouvelle le cadam a marre et
j'ai besoin que tu m'aimes tu vas
[Musique]
moi j'aurais su quoi faire je t'aurais
retourner et placer la tête comme ça
contre le réfrigérateur 1 c'est très
sain